each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
go ahead and get started and I'm sure
there'll be a couple more folks rolling
in us as uh as time ticks down it's my
pleasure to introduce at Colgate and
Michael Peskin from Northwestern
University today Edie and Michael are in
the mechanical engineering department
but it also co-directs the the siegel
design institute with don norman out
there they've got an impressive slate of
domains they work across everything from
human machine interaction to robotics to
tele manipulation and obviously haptics
which they will talk to us about today
they've started a numerous numerous
spin-off companies most of which are
amazingly successful and they're going
to talk to us about some of their work
on surface optics today and then have a
live demo in fact which is always
exciting so Edie so thanks much doesn't
really appreciate the chance to be here
and to speak about the work we've been
doing so I'll do the speaking for the
talk but this is a very very much work
that Michael and I have collaborated on
here over the past few years as we've
collaborated on many things through the
years so so yeah the topic today is is
surface haptics yeah a lot of the work
that we've done through the years is
just haptics haptic so you know the
early days the haptics a lot of it was
sort of fundamentally occurring in three
dimensions so devices probably many of
you are familiar with devices like the
Phantom small robot that you can grab on
to sensors on it that tell a virtual
environment running on some computer you
know where you are in that virtual
environment if you run into things
physics based models compute the
interaction forces those forces are fed
back through actuators and and that
closed-loop interaction creates a very
very compelling sense of physical
interaction with that virtual world but
the world has changed a lot in and you
know touchscreen devices like this one
from Apple but many others have really
changed the landscape of haptics in
recent years because the touch surface
has become such a prevalent
interface that all of us use in our
daily lives in multiple instantiations
and so the challenge has been you know
down from that three-dimensional world
into a two-dimensional world
how do you do haptics in a meaningful
way on a surface so I defined surface
haptics is providing programmable haptic
effects on physical surfaces and the
real question that's driven a lot of our
work has been how do you do this I'll
give just a very very brief review of
some of the techniques that people have
explored and then really kind of focus
on what we've been doing probably one of
the most sort of time-honored approaches
to this has been what's called by many
Eastham which is the idea of actually
driving a certain amount of current
through the through the tissue in order
to cause nerves to fire yeah and and the
it's it's really a pretty interesting
idea after all the information that's
traveling to your brain about touch is
ultimately conduct along nerves which
are electrical signals that the
difficulty of it is that in fact in your
fingertip you've got a whole
constellation of different sorts of
mechanoreceptors for different
mechanoreceptors responding to things
like deformation or vibration or stretch
as well as raw nerve endings for things
like you know temperature and pain and
the problem with this approach is that
it's not very selective it's very
difficult to to make it select out
particular types of mechanoreceptors and
generate particular sorts of responses
so this is a challenging area in terms
of generating more natural interactions
an approach which is really the leading
approach out there in the world today is
vibrotactile there's a lot of good
reasons why one would use vibrotactile
for providing haptic feedback it's a
very easy thing to generate from an
engineering standpoint certainly there's
a lot of room for optimization but
fundamentally generating vibrations is a
pretty straightforward thing to do but
more to the point we are very well
adapted to feel vibration sort of a very
famous curve I should have included in
the talk that shows that around 250 300
Hertz you can feel the vibration
amplitudes of a tenth of a micron it
doesn't take much to Jenner
a perceptible response on the other hand
I've been told by some and sort of the
the neuroscience community that part of
the reason we're so sensitive vibration
is that if a fly lands on your arm if
you want to be able to slide it really
fast right so this underlies the point
that haptics is really a whole set of
sensory perceptual systems that have
different functions and you know a lot
of those functions have to do with
knowing when and where and your body
you're in contact with the world
including flies and mosquitoes and so
there are other things that have become
important about important for like
grabbing onto things manipulating things
identifying objects by touch and
vibration isn't necessarily as important
a part of those what many people would
consider kind of a holy grail of its
surface haptics is modulating the shape
of the surface you know so there's been
a lot of work on things like pen arrays
deformable surfaces very cool stuff but
obviously very very high level of
technical challenge and and often doing
this sort of thing has some sort of very
deep incompatibility other sorts of
things that you might want to do on a
surface like get light through it so I'm
not going to be talking much about this
although I think the long-term future
probably these approaches have a lot of
promise so what I'll be talking about is
the use of sheer force this has really
been our focus this is probably the
earliest example I know in the
literature of using sheer force for
haptics this was a device where there
was literally a transparent cover on top
of a display and actuators that would
tug on that cover and it's very very
much a conventional type of
force-feedback haptic device not
necessarily very practical as something
that could be implemented in many
different settings but but sort of a
very clever idea this was from 2004
following that not a lot of work was
done on doing sheer force I suspect
because of the difficulty of doing this
generating these forces on the bare
finger I'll come back to that in a
moment but there are very deep reasons
why sheer force
a important thing to do one of the very
early and best-known pieces of work in
the field of haptics was Margaret
Minsky's Margaret was Marvin's daughter
development of the sand paper system
work she did at the MIT Media Lab in the
late 80s and into the 90s
she took a a force reflecting of force
feedback joystick that can move only in
the plane but program various force
effects in the plane and was able to
demonstrate that people could perceive
textures if you will sort of had the
perception of bumps or ridges that would
penetrate out of the plane so even
though the motion was only in the plane
people would perceive a
three-dimensional interaction then
Vincent Heyward and his student Gabriele
Robles tell Atari took this further and
in a very carefully controlled study
that they published in a nature paper
around 2001 and what they demonstrated
was really pretty cool they had people
literally moving over bumps not actually
feeling the local shape so they were
fingers were on a flat object but the
object was moving up and down and
following that bump contour then they
had people moving in a perfectly flat
plane but playing a set of forces that
were essentially the reaction forces one
would feel from traversing a bump both
cases led to the percept of a bump but
then they combine them actually they
took the physical bump and turned into a
whole but kept playing the force percept
of the bump and they're really amazing
result is that the first percept could
be strong enough to overwhelm the
percept coming from actual up and down
motion so you'd feel a bump even though
you're physically moving down through a
hole sure this was done also with a
kinesthetic force feedback display no
this was this in this version what they
were doing was very much what's shown
here a mechanical device that would
literally move up and down but no force
feedback this was done with force
feedback using motors a closed loop
system that way
only inflamed right and then they
combine the two so pretty important and
that it shows the existence of a haptic
illusion that's really quite powerful
right that you can you can perceive
shape three-dimensional shape based on a
pattern of forces in space so these are
pretty cool and to me very inspiring but
again they both dealt with systems where
you were grabbing on to or being bound
to a device and the challenge really is
how do you do this on a bare finger
right that's the challenge that Michael
and I've been working on over the past
few years how do we control the sheer
force vector acting in the plane on a
bare finger so here's how we approach
that problem we use friction it'd be
nice to think in terms of you know what
are all the different physics you could
you could appeal to for pushing around a
finger it'd be great if your finger was
you know electro quote it was magnetic
and you can essentially build a linear
motor but but really what you've got to
play with as far as I know is friction
so I show this classic equation of
kinetic friction a Coulomb model of
kinetic friction which is almost
certainly wrong for instance your finger
being deformable has a nonlinear depends
upon normal force but I don't really
care about the details right now what I
care about is is the Constituent pieces
okay they are coefficient of friction
normal force and relative velocity how
slippery is that surface you're
contacting how much normal forces there
with that surface and then what's the
relative velocity these are the things
that we can potentially manipulate in
order to control that force vector and
we've been working on all the pieces so
I'm going to kind of break this down
into the pieces and then you know we'll
show you demos at the end of essentially
all those pieces so coefficient of
friction was really where we got our
start we kind of stumbled into this a
grad student discovering that putting a
finger on a vibrating surface that
surface felt more slippery it turned out
other people have been seeing that as
well back in 95 Watson Tommy Fukui
published the first paper in this area
in which they had they used a big old
ultrasonic horn vibrator to cause a
plate to vibrate and they put sandpaper
on it
when vibrating at 75 kilohertz so way
into the ultrasonic range people still
felt that sandpaper getting less less
rough and others have worked on this as
well what we've done is take that and
build something we call the tee pad
where we've integrated those ultrasonic
out-of-plane vibrations with a glass
surface and we can take this glass
surface and make it more or less
slippery this is one of our prototype
devices just to explain a little bit
more about how that works it's supposed
to be a movie but I think I don't have
it set up quite right so I'll just talk
over it what we're looking at here is
actually a measured profile of the the
wave form or the the mode shape of a
piece of glass it's vibrating at a
resonance measured with a laser Doppler
vibrometer so there's a set of
piezoelectric actuators glued to the
glass over here and we're exciting those
things causing causing the glass to Bend
and then doing that at a resonant
frequency that has this particular mode
shape so basically every point on the
surface is kind of moving up and down
and one brings the finger down on it and
so the surface is basically bouncing up
and down against the finger an
interesting question is why does that
cause friction to go down and there's a
bunch of papers in the literature
including ours that claim that the
mechanism is this I'll show you in a
moment that it may not really be but
it's like this imagine that this upper
plate represents the finger and this is
the plate moving up and down there's
some air in between and air has both
compliance and error has viscosity and
both are nonlinear effects there none
one they are not linearly modulated by
the the gap between the upper and lower
plates so that as the lower plate gets
close and squeezes the air the pressure
peak set above atmospheric so this
dashed black line would represent
atmospheric pressure you get a pressure
of peak but of course you're trying to
squeeze that air out on the other hand
the gap can get quite small so biscuits
effects can become pronounced and we're
talking about gaps there's some micron
here so really quite small
as it moves away you get a larger gap
pressure drops below atmospheric on the
other hand the gap gets large so it's
fairly easy for air to flow in and the
net of this is that it acts like a pump
and pumps a bit of air in between the
plates and the average pressure goes
above atmospheric and so you're writing
on an air bearing at least that was sort
of the theory we've recently been able
to take data using a laser Doppler
vibrometer that suggests it's not quite
right the actual data we took is
represented down here in the black the
solid black line is the velocity of the
surface so this is a surface vibrating
it's something like approximately 25
kilohertz and then the dashed line is
the velocity of the finger and the thing
to note is that it has this very
precipitous drop followed by a little
phase where the velocities are almost
matched and so if you integrate this
data you get data that looks like the
blue Uppal of displacement data the
thing is there's always an offset of
integration and so these two blue lines
we don't really know where they are
vertically relative one another so what
we've done is just slid them up to where
we think they ought to be and based on
what we're seeing here it sure looks
like contact occurs because we've got
this little area where there's this
precipitous drop in velocity followed by
kind of a tracking so it actually looks
like contact is occurring and the
fingers then essentially bouncing off
the surface so we've done a bit of
modeling and analysis with that and
indeed there's a very good reason to
think that that would have the effect of
reducing the apparent friction
coefficient in fact the behavior becomes
a bit more like a viscous relationship
as opposed to a kilometre in
relationship but but with a very low low
viscous coefficient
what we're doing is we've got this piece
of glass that's in here vibrating we
bring the finger up underneath it and
then we use like a silver sharpie and
make the finger a bit reflective and
look through the glass right at it it
really is yeah which has been sort of
nicely flattened out because of the fact
that it's touching a glass yeah so I'll
say I might say a bit more about that in
just a moment but those are the sorts of
profiles that we see so again a parent
contact we also make friction
measurements so we have a little rig
where we measure normal force and shear
force and we can relate the ratio of
those to the friction coefficient to the
amplitude of motion measured again with
that laser Doppler vibrometer and you
see is very marked relationship I mean
it's it's really a pretty impressive
effect if you start when things are off
with a coefficient of friction above a
mu of about 0.5 it drops by about an
order of magnitude over a reasonable
range of motion amplitudes feels very
nice as well it's very nice slippery air
bearing feeling you can also turn it on
and off really fast so here's some data
where we've got the normal force and
frictional force both measured with the
rig and then we suddenly turn the device
on and that apparent coefficient of
friction drops down significantly you
notice here an even higher coefficient
of friction while the device is off that
varies a lot with both individual and
with the preparation of the glass
surface so here it's close to one but
again drops down to something quite
small not only that you can modulate the
effect you don't have to have friction
just on or off so here we're trying to
generate a sort of a bumpy feeling on a
surface and you see that indeed the
friction coefficient is not smoothly
modulated but but certainly not not just
not off either so we can generate some
kind of nice effects that way there are
problems with this approach one problem
is audible noise so you get this surface
it's vibrating up and down we try to
operate in the ultrasonic regime so you
can't hear it and so this is a
frequency response looking at the motion
of the surface itself it's quite
beautiful all the energy is here had you
know in this case 26 kilohertz can't
hear that but when we look through the
glass at the finger we often see things
like this where here's the frequency of
the glass and now here's the frequency
of the finger so what's going on there
well if you go back and look in the time
domain you see things happening like
this it's the same thing I showed you
before a little greater amplitude of the
glass and suddenly you see the finger
skipping a beat so we're getting a sub
harmonic so now that the most of the
energy of the vibration of the finger is
at half the frequency of the glass and
so it's a period doubling phenomenon see
your finger is acting like a little
loudspeaker generating noise at an
audible frequency so this is a bit of a
problem I think it's kind of interesting
here is that you'll see if I've
highlighted that me see you see period
doubling but you also see this effect
here where without apparent contact the
motion of the finger kind of turns
around and parts from the glass now why
would it do that probably because there
is in fact a squeezed film as well as
contact so this is a bit of an issue
it's a difficult problem to solve it's
an area of ongoing research frankly the
most pragmatic solution is simply to
increase the frequency of excitation of
the glass surface even more that does
come up some cost of energy so so a
interesting problem so just to summarize
you can generate some very nice
high-quality haptic effects by making
surfaces more slippery it is difficult
to eliminate to subharmonics we can just
operate at higher frequencies but I
suspect that there's more elegant
solutions out there waiting for us ok so
now let me talk about normal force so so
that was kind of how we make things more
slippery how can we modulate the normal
force well the main technique that we
and others are using here is
electrostatic and two of the demos that
we brought here today
are electrostatic devices so those who
have been following haptics in recent
years has certainly seen things from the
finished company sense AG and more
recently from Disney disease research
labs the Tesla touch device and these
are operating electrostatically the idea
is pretty straightforward it's to take a
conductive surface apply a potential to
it have it covered by some dielectric
insulator and then bring the finger down
on the surface the finger assumption
actresses the second plate of a parallel
plate capacitor that plus and minus
charges developed they tracked one
another you get a normal force and then
that normal force can be turned on and
off as the finger moves in order to
generate the sensation of vibrations you
know a lot of people asked cheek and you
really generate very much normal force
this way and it turns out that in
principle you can't so it's sort of the
classic equation of the force that
develops in the parallel plate setting
where a is the area of the finger in
contact we use the applied voltage D is
the essentially the gap of the thickness
of the dielectric here this epsilon is
the relative permittivity and using
reasonable values you can come up with
an estimate of normal forces on the
order of up to Newton and maybe even a
bit greater so that's not bad if you
have that much normal force to work with
and you have coefficients of friction
that are on the order of 1/2 to 1 that
means you should be able to vary the
lateral forces by up to half a Newton or
a Newton which is a very significant
effect but if you actually look at the
devices the ones I showed before I don't
think you're seeing nearly as much
variation in normal force and a big
reason for that is that your finger
leaks leaks charge in particular so if
we look at the finger it has it has the
properties of a dielectric but it also
has the properties of a resistive
conductive material
so it has finite resistivity so although
there's a lot I don't know about the
nature of say the charge carriers and so
forth charge does literally leak through
the finger and once it's through is
going to end up on the surface so that
the electric field acting on those
charges is no longer pulling on the
finger it's pulling on charges that
reside on the surface and does that
means that the the forces on the finger
decay so what's important is the time
constant of that decay and so we've made
some measurements that suggest that that
time constant can be as short as a
hundred microseconds or less and that
helps explain why even though in
principle you might get fairly large
forces and practice if you're varying
that that force it say to 300 Hertz a
lot of the time not much is going on and
so on average the forces are lower so
we've done a fair amount of work which
reflects itself in these prototypes to
to counteract that effect primarily by
using an AC technique another thing that
I know I didn't put it into the
presentation but I know is of interest
to some people here is that these
previous devices have required grounding
the the finger and that's sort of a very
practical issue and so you'll find that
we've also done things a little bit
differently in order to eliminate that
problem so that no longer is it
necessary to do what I'm showing here
which is directly ground ground the
finger so we've done these things
because our interest is not so much just
in generating the sensation of a texture
or vibration that's a worthwhile goal
but as I talked about earlier we're very
focused on this shear forces use lateral
forces so that we can do force feedback
and and first say more about that later
but if you really want to do force
feedback then you really want to be able
to generate significant forces and for
that you really want to achieve as close
to the sort of theoretical maximum as
you can
this is some data that we've taken that
show that in fact we do pretty well
here's yet another very different
friction coefficient this is
an individual shall weigh with slippery
fingers on slippery glass and so when
everything's off he's got a coefficient
of friction in this particular case of
about 0.15 we rarely see things that low
but he must have gotten a hole I don't
know what was going on that day but when
we turned the effect on you see a
sniffing in this case about a 50%
increase in the effective friction
coefficient so that means that the
normal force is being increased by about
50% so a pretty significant effect and
we've we've got lots of data like this
one of the issues that we run into is
that it varies a lot across individuals
but we can pretty much always generate a
significant effect so we will show you
some demos of this but the use of
electrostatics to increase normal force
has a lot of virtues it's very fast when
we turn this effect on and off more or
less instantly consumes very little
power I didn't actually mention the
nodal lines although I showed them in
that waveform that I showed the the
modal shape of our vibrating surface and
those are areas where we get less of an
effect with the friction reduction and
then I mentioned the noise issues those
are gone here so we have a very nice
simple system the size of the effect
needs to be saved further and talked a
lot about that we want to maximize it
all that we can so that we can actually
use this to generate big lateral forces
on the finger and then the other thing
is that we're increasing friction rather
than decreasing it so the the aesthetic
of it is very different and I would say
on the whole not quite as pleasing maybe
not a very big deal the way that we
intend to be using it in the future
which is to actually push the finger not
just resist it and so let me now talk
about that so this to my mind is the
really exciting part of all this so I've
talked about mu and n but the thing is
friction forces are dissipative forces
all right so so friction is always
acting to resist the relative motion
between the two surfaces and so
everything we've talked about so far the
direction of the force is always
opposite your motion and that's not
satisfactory if we're really trying to
do a force feedback we really need to be
able to actively control the force on
the finger control habit
push the thing or have it push two
different directions if I want to
simulate sliding along an edge well my
velocity is parallel to the edge but the
normal force is primarily perpendicular
to the edge and I really would like to
be able to do something like that so I'm
left with no choice but to move not just
the finger but the surface as well
that's the really big idea here how can
we actually move the surface so that we
can turn this resistive effect this
dissipative effect into an actuator and
so we've developed a few devices that do
this
the first was something we called the
shiver pad which has for a compliment
called a swirl pad and then more
recently something we call the lateral
pad which we have here the idea is
pretty simple it's to vibrate the
surface and then to synchronize those
vibrations with levels of frictionless
that's what we do with the shirt pad
which you're showing here so here we're
showing how we would generate a force to
the right and basically we make it high
friction as it moves to the right and
then a low friction as it sort of slips
back under your finger and then the idea
is to do that fast enough that you don't
perceive the underlying vibration you
only perceive the average forcing and so
with shiver pads we were able to do this
up to about 850 Hertz which is fast
enough that you don't really feel it you
have some some amount of sensitivity a
10 or 50 Hertz but not much we were not
able to go at a higher frequency because
it takes time to turn on and off
friction the way we were turning on and
off friction was by using these
out-of-plane vibrations it takes time to
build those up and have them decay but
it does work I'll show you a little bit
of data these are some of the early
prototypes this was a tee pad the device
that vibrates out-of-plane lets us
control friction and then it was hooked
up initially just to a speaker and then
eventually to a voice coil in order to
cause it to vibrate side-to-side and
this is data with it vibrating only it's
a 40 Hertz but just showing kind of that
in fact it really does work we have
periods where the tee pad is on and it's
very low friction so your forces here
are very close to zero and then periods
where it's often so the forces are much
higher
so the blue line is an average force
what you see in this case is almost a
hundred militants which is really pretty
significant in terms of generating
haptic effects so the idea then is to
synchronize this with a knowledge of
where your finger is in order to
generate force feedback effects so I'm
going back to things like the the the
mumps as virtual bumps from the Heyward
and Robles dilatory that I showed you
earlier where they were showing that
these in-plane force fields generate the
perception of bumps or holes out of the
plane and so that's what we're trying to
do here and this is as this is now
actual data up here is actual force data
and here it is integrated because when
you integrate it you get essentially a
potential function and the shape of that
potential function gives you a sense of
the percept so this is the percept of a
bump the percept of a whole the way we
do it is we measure the fingers location
and then we modulate the direction and
the amplitude of the force to generate
the corresponding force profile so this
is kind of a restoring spring and black
and the green is a unstable spring if
you will and then you can begin to put
those together and do things like this
the toggle switch this is sort of my
favorite little effect where we have to
line sinks kind of holes if you will
separated by a line source a bump and
again actual force data taken here and
integrated to give you the potential
function so you see two potential wells
separated by potential Hill and so the
idea is that your finger is going to
kind of go pop pop pop as if you were
walking into the room and flipping a
light switch which of course here you
don't have such old technology but you
know what I mean so this is sort of my
favorite video that we've taken it's
hard to do these things
see haptics in a video but I think you
can see it here you can see the finger
pop-pop-pop-pop back and forth and
really a pretty compelling compelling
effect so to me that's this is kind of
what it's all about is generating these
closed-loop force feedback experiences
matically different sorts of
interactions inner you're capable of
doing with sages vibrotactile but still
pretty clumsy device vibrating at 850
Hertz makes it pretty annoying noise we
were very interested in doing everything
in the ultrasonic frequency range and so
that led to the lateral pad where what
we were doing is synchronizing in plane
and out of plane vibrations both at
ultrasonic frequencies so we have the
demo here today basically what we've got
is a piece of glass here looks kind of
the shape of microscope slide we've got
a couple of piers a disc glued to it and
when we activate that we cause it to
bend the mode shape of bending is shown
here so basically it's moving up and
down a lot in the middle where you put
your finger and then we pull these piezo
discs out of these old tight buds the
ultrasonic spot removers we can get
really cheap and we throw them on the
ends here and so we have these piezo
stacks here and here and they are
reacting against these in masses and
causing the whole glass to move side to
side and again the mode shape is shown
here so a lot of side-to-side motion in
the middle where you put your finger and
then we tune these things to resonate at
essentially the same frequency and then
we drive them with the same frequency
but we control the phase relationship
between the out of plane and end plane
motions and when you do that so you can
kind of imagine that the plane the
surface now is not only going up and
down but also side-to-side so it's kind
of making elliptical motions this way or
that way and by controlling that phase
relationship we can control the lateral
force quite well and so here's the
relative phase between the two and this
is a lateral force coefficient which is
lateral force divided by a normal force
you can kind of get a sense of the scale
of the effect by thinking about this
visa V friction is not friction it's
active but but with friction
coefficients of about 0.15 how sticky is
such a surface well that's about how
strong this surface drives which is not
as strong as we'd like we'd like
about double this but but I think you'll
find that you can feel some pretty cool
effects so we do much the same sort of
thing one thing that we were very
interested in is what motions of the
surface are actually creating the
largest forces and so we made some
measurements using again a laser Doppler
vibrometer looking both straight down at
the glass which gives us the up-and-down
motion and then tilting the glass so
that we're able to measure some
component of the sideways motion as well
and then once you run through the math
what you find is that the the motion of
the glass it generates the largest
forces on the finger are when and the up
and down and side-to-side are in phase
which basically means that the glass is
coming up and hitting the finger and
there's a little pulses like this which
is exactly the same thing that that tea
pad the friction reduction device would
do it's moving straight up and down but
as you move this way you sort of tilt
that angle in the frame of the finger
and so this is sort of tilting it
without the finger moving and so it
generates the steady forces on the
finger we can do the same sort of things
to generate virtual bumps again actual
data take in the forces in this case are
up to about 50 Milanoo Tain's so only
about half as strong as that sugar pad
so again we very active very researches
how do you make this effect stronger
so to summarize you know this is really
the key part of it we've more or less
proven that that these coordinated
effects work but there's a fair amount
remaining to be done in terms especially
of of increasing the force levels so
those are the big effects I will shut up
now how high these are some of the the
wonderful students who've really done
all this work we've had some great
collaborations and support from the NSF
as well as department transportation and
Ford and so I think we can take
questions and run demos
I'm gonna move this over but well we
questions a lot of the wheels and all
devices
well I think as you can kind of see from
the nature of the talk where we're more
interested in kind of the neighboring
technology that's kind of our strength
and so part of the reason that we
collaborate with people hoping to start
collaborating with Hong and a Karen
McLean is someone who looks a lot at
human-computer interface so we're
starting to do those things so that we
can begin to sort of get feedback in
terms of understanding what the needs of
the applications are so I guess the
answer is that we're somewhat agnostic
but we're trying to learn more and I
guess one of the reasons that we're here
today is to try and understand what
vision you may have in terms of haptic
sync and how it can have an effect but I
do think that having spent a lot of
years of my life studying haptics that I
feel very very strongly that that this
paradigm we're doing force feedback
whether whether we've optimized it or
not is another question but this
paradigm you're doing force feedback is
immensely more powerful than the
paradigm of vibrotactile and
therefore I think very worthy of being
developed for applications and and all
these arenas let me just add to that
that for mobile devices which is you
know very attractive market power is of
course an enormous concern and our
yeahso devices are pretty high powered
devices and they'd have to be reduced by
orders of magnitude to be sort of in the
ballpark for mobile devices but the the
electrostatics are closer better yeah
a little bit about efforts to manage the
force but area because it seems to all
of these devices seem to function on the
whole plane yeah it's a great question
so we we have we have plans for we have
an we have a pathway toward localizing
it I'd say the one technology that
doesn't necessarily act over the entire
plane is the electrostatic all right
things that involve the mechanical
vibration it's pretty tough to build
something where you can really localize
the vibrations without consuming even
more energy so but the electrostatics
not a problem there so that's really the
the key enabling technology so I didn't
say here but really our our path forward
is combining the electrostatics with the
N plane vibrations go ahead Michael I
just wanted to make absolutely clear
that when you're working with one finger
on a surface because you can read the
position of the finger you can make it
as if you had localized the effect but
as soon as you've got more than one
finger or as you were saying if you want
to conserve power be really nice to
actually localize the uh make it
different than different parts of the
plane
great fingers now
you could sneaky spin to the right spot
but that's
I wouldn't write that off
I mean it's a deeper discussion of how
you do that but but I think the key is
that the electrostatics can be localized
and that's probably all that you need if
you can if you can get the vibrations
right we develop both we development
with per have to explore from ICP words
direct an interesting devices all these
things we looked at a wide variety of
devices but we're gently trying to do is
imitate dumb switch clicks other
sensations that don't require your
finger or don't expect your finger to
move laterally you coming down on
something so we we've flipped we've had
sense they come in and the effectors
effects are kind of need stroke across
yeah especially they'll put it into an
emissive displaces stroke across
tires feeling
um it's been interesting but not really
appropriate for our occasion it's Tokyo
cross anything our fingers aren't moving
anywhere right what's quite interesting
about this is your finger doesn't looks
like your finger could need one spot and
feel of lateral force that gets really
quite interested in ways of giving cues
to your finger that's in the wrong spot
right which makes it more likely to we
looking for a bias free interaction
absolutely right that's the thing that's
always been funny for what nice what we
call highest right size interaction
right so I'm going to take your eyes off
the road while you're texting whatever
yes yeah yes yeah you know as we get
away from more work we get flatter and
flatter ease or interfaces keys they
don't move anymore
preserve the sense of precision
red spider there's nothing about
frustrating that smartphone of the south
right in there oh good
so we do have a demo of us off keyboard
moral soft keys I think four keys and
again I'll emphasize that the level of
forces isn't where it really needs to be
but despite that I think you'll find
that especially sort of after just a
little learning period it's quite
remarkable because the soft the way we
do it we create these potential wells so
not only is it a steady force but it's
really trying to stabilize your finger
at the center of the key I find it
personally to be a pretty compelling
affect how you there's a bend up behind
your your you're exciting with coherent
source your thought about setting up x
and y static waves for changing the
vibration that's like an acoustic load
right yeah I think I understand what
you're saying and in to some extent and
Michael you may want to chime in here
but some extent that's what we do we
these these are these vibrations are
standing waves they are resonances if
you will we really try to operate at
resonance because it's very efficient
what some people want us to encourage us
to do is look at ways of exciting from
the corners and focusing energy at
certain spots we have not put the energy
into that it's interesting but I suspect
my Mistral senses it's not going to be
the thing I want to put my time into so
I think it's to be very very difficult
to avoid significant amount of energy
and lower frequencies and then in
general that's not going to be a very
efficient approach so rather what we've
done is what I think Michael mentioned
earlier which is we measure where the
finger is and then we control the
effects there may the effects might be
happening over the entire surface but if
you know where the finger is but
that drivers and further manipulating
parts right well they have ability to
move two or three pucks yes table
simultaneously yeah but the when you
play back the video right I don't think
they quite have the audio oh no they're
they're they're working way down in the
audible realms men's community do that
or self-assembly yeah yeah we have a
colleague in northwestern Kevin Len sure
does that sort of work - you can go on
on - see videos something that they call
the pea pod which is super cool where
they vibrate not only in two plane but
they do some little tilting action as
well and you can create some very very
nice force fields or velocity fields for
parts but but it's hard for me to
imagine those things working in our
realm I think it's very critical that we
get into the ultrasonic regime certainly
you must be above where you get that
tactile perception and you can get some
perception up to you know kilohertz or
so so you've got to be above that but
then once you're there it's very
difficult to not be you know coupling
energy acoustically and so getting into
the ultrasonic regime seems to be very
very critical the other thing I want to
say is you know our path really is to
integrate this motion and to get rid of
these motions these motions whether you
hear it or not are coupling into the air
and throwing energy out there and it's
just not an efficient way to do things
so so really the the pathway forward is
to combine this lateral motion of this
device with the electrostatic control of
normal force from these devices okay and
that's the thing that will label us - I
think in a very power efficient way be
able to control and also in a very
authoritative way control forces on
multiple fingers that's the focus
building structures resonate at those
higher
the reason why I asked it was
we tend to use not case of stack which
which are not as stiff I think there's
this thing so it's if you find trouble
can't get there yeah we can get there we
can get there to face so sticks modeling
and and there's a fair amount of
practical issues but actually when you
when you look at the demo in the middle
there you'll see both stack piezo is
moving this thing laterally and also dis
be is those which are placed at the
right spot Thun computate for a
estimated computationally in order to
flex the that the the vertical
vibrations are done by flexing the
surface and then it goes into a wave
motion with disks not exactly the
bat-ray thing but they curve they try to
contract and WordArt they been the the
surface contracting it when it's glued
to the surface so it's caused cousin
Benny
that would do it too this has done just
what they were not bending but it's go
we have been like doing the whole thing
right now so that works actually we've
done very well with it not only with
like fancy piezo is just with these you
know things that are used as is that
buzzer is ladies yeah just totally junk
PA Zoe's even those if we if we glue
them down and we can we can put the with
the glass into a into a resonant
amplifier standing mode or residence is
essentially your static displacement sir
let's say that's the micro what we've
been actually trying to do surfaces
residence
well because residence is getting in our
way he's gonna make a nice little but
yeah we end up with a ring but you're
vibrating in a frequency range where you
want the person to feel that way for me
so right so but what we found this piece
as we're trying to move the resonant
frequency of using cares are just some
fairly heavy glass thoughts we get 2 3 4
500 Hertz and have a really hard time
getting an entire so I'm just thinking
your application is different but the
structures are somewhere I don't know
how you managed to get up to the 10
as residents but we can't get past four
five hundred I'm thinking maybe it's
because you're PSO stacks or it's so
much stiffer than I think I know the
answer I think you can do it just as
well as we can the issue is that we're
looking for only a micron of motion
because we're not trying to generate
anything that you actually feel we're
trying to modulate this slipperiness
factor and you're trying to generate
things that you feel right so it's it's
a different goal what did the XE Carla
challenge yeah well at high frequencies
of course moving in a significant
distance would be an enormous amount of
energy just physically in the glass and
and there's nothing you can do an
efficiency that's gonna change that I
just wanted to go back to your earlier
comment about sort of clicking and
finding your place I find that idea of
you know home keys pretty exciting but
I'd hope that as glass becomes more
interesting you know as soon as women
have the ability to maybe individually
drive your fingers around that the this
kind of interaction with the glass
becomes just one of many many user
interface pictures I mean we see that a
little bit even for text entry now with
things like swipe but I have no idea and
this is what you guys are really good at
is what could be the new ways what could
be the ways of optic user interface then
you could have once you have the ability
to push you around here I thought about
experimenting with different textures of
glass I'll be ecstatic that close to the
display you can get away with
with very large aramis modulation the
surface of the glass you mean the actual
texture of the glass that's something we
would like to do a lot more with one of
the struggles for us as we're basically
a robotics lab that's been sort of
slowly coming up the learning curve on
things like you know thin films and
material processing and so we definitely
end up with different textures of glass
not necessarily by by by intention so I
think you'll everything here today is
pretty pretty smooth which isn't
necessarily what we really want I'm
gonna smooth that tends to promote
stick-slip phenomena which affects the
mechanics of the interaction so there's
a lot there's a lot of a lot of work to
be done there not only can you can you
vary the surface texture and rough
surfaces tend to be lower friction then
yes they're very smooth ones but you can
there are also oleophobic glasses and
there's there's all sorts of amazing
stuff that these people can do on the
surface of glass that would that are
mysterious to us theory on say
electroactive polymers with something
some people think is
future haptics once they leave dynamic
range is increased well I think I think
they'd certainly have a role but it's
not the way I pressed up the world isn't
so much whether you're using ei peas or
Bezos or electrostatics in order to do
your actuation the way I pushed the
world is what are you doing with your
actuation and I guess my message here
today is don't put your stock in
vibrotactile okay put your stock in
force force feedback because I think
that from the standpoint of haptics and
what we do with it in the world the
sorts of effects that we want to
generate are ones that are based upon
and closing the loop with with force
feedback so if you can use EAPs as part
of a force feedback system which I think
you can then absolutely but so that's
just that's just sort of my parsing
alright we want to show some demos